joe biden is taking a huge risk the new
u.s
president is making reform of america's
outdated immigration system
one of his key policy goals critics
though
say any hint of a more humane approach
will only trigger a new surge of
immigrants heading for america's
southern border meanwhile the eu is
taking a tougher approach one that
observers say
amounts to keeping migrants out of
europe whatever it costs
so on to the point we ask u.s
immigration reform biden's alternative
to fortress europe
thanks very much indeed for joining us
here on to the point where my guests
here in the studio
are anna maria alvarez a migration
expert from
costa rica she says what joe biden can
learn from
europe is that inclusion needs to be a
key
element of the narrative also with us is
helen posner from the german daily
developed he thinks
if you want right-wing wing populists to
rule europe all you have to do is
open the borders and a very warm welcome
to to joseph hutchinson u.s lawyer and
activist his opinion biden's ambitious
plans are doomed to fail
in the anti-democratic u.s senate
oh we've got so much to talk about and
let's begin with you as i said joe biden
has made reform of america's immigration
system
one of the central planks of his
politics for the for
years to come now are you surprised
i'm not surprised because a lot of
organized
groups from the civil society and
grassroots organizations
made him go to power today and he owned
it to them
many of them were organizations and
grassroots um
organizing groups which are you know in
the basis of migrant
uh migrant populations as well so i'm
not surprised he owned it to them he was
part of his narrative throughout the
campaign
um i'm just basically surprised that he
started his first day
with this ambitious plan which
essentially right now one
huge risk absolutely but they were not
prepared and they're not prepared and we
have seen it and
been unfolding this in these days that
they're not prepared they're still
planning they're still
working on that okay we'll talk about
how how they're not prepared in just a
second uh joseph joseph hutchinson
immigration is one of the most diversive
issues in the u.s one of the diver most
divisive issues in the world i think
what makes it so polarizing
um i think unfortunately that we've let
right-wing populists control the
narrative
um so you know people don't like data or
facts anymore
when you look at the data immigration is
a net positive for pretty much every
society you look at
wages increase people do better
there's more diversification immigrants
generally have
either the social capital or just the
gumption to come and start new
businesses so
immigration isn't that positive but
that's like a wonky detail that most
people don't understand
it's easier to you know resort to this
fear
and um i also i want to be very careful
when i say that i
understand the fear right so people are
afraid for their security they're afraid
for their livelihoods
but i think what we need to understand
is the people coming
to you know i say europe or the united
states
those are the same things they want they
want to be free from that
fear and they want to have the same
security we understand here so
what we're lacking is the empathy and
really the understanding contextually
why are these people leaving well the
biden administration is going to do it
all
so differently one senior official says
quote
they're going to restore compassion and
order to our immigration system
correct the divisive inhumane and
immoral policies of the last four years
it's a tall order well uh donald trump
broke the country
um so there's just a lot to fix
ellen donald trump broke the country
yeah
i would i would agree though um looking
at the numbers
of immigration i mean what we're talking
about they actually didn't go down
as much as donald trump promised they
would go down so i mean
he the worst thing about trump was his
rhetorics right
and um and uh in many ways he was just
continuing what
the obama administration started i mean
fence building that wasn't his invention
right
obama started that so biden's changed
the rhetoric
right uh uh but how much will really
change
remains to be seen i mean what biden's
saying now
it's word for word what the european
union has been saying all along and you
know if you listen to fonder lion or
anyone
commissioned president they will you
know they'll sign on the
deadline and what on what biden's just
said so the question is really
what actually happens and it remains for
any government they have to control the
board doesn't control who comes in who
stays out there
what you referred to already is but
biden has changed the rhetoric but that
is
he he's adopting you could say a softer
tone
i think that might be one way of
describing it yeah but it has meant
there has been a surge
towards the border already absolutely
and i agree with you i mean
sometimes i mean the change needed to
happen
from a narrative perspective but there's
so much to be done
for example it's very important that we
understand that the first day
when he entered to the white house he
delivered these executive orders
but there's one executive order
regarding the migration
protection protocol which was set by
trump he said we're going to review it
he has never said we're going to change
it and that's essentially
what i am very concerned because
actually in two days ago in in
in the press briefing we heard that they
were going to invite roberta
jacobson which is the new uh chief in
command who's going to take care of the
ambassador for these issues exactly um
so
i it makes me feel like they're still
not aligned with what they're going to
say
what is the plan what's going to be the
what's going to be the plan what's
going to be the the the actions to be
unfolding in the southern border and we
still don't know that
so yeah and critics say that uh this is
you know there's a pandemic on this is
not the time
to be revamping the system or tweaking
the system what do you say joseph um
this is
exactly the time because so i i would
disagree that there's now a surge
because
um he's in office i think uh there's
this natural
pressure that pushes people to the
united states but
especially in light of the pandemic what
we've realized and you know i'm
frankly shocked the united states with
their vaccination campaign is doing so
well
what we're realizing is you need quick
decisive actions you're shocked
impressed
i'm impressed yes it's interesting
you you just mentioned roberto jackson
and uh
no jacobson there and then the woman
who's responsible for
uh biden policy toward on the southern
border yeah
she said what we're trying to do is walk
the walk and chew the gum at the same
time that we're trying to be sort of
kind and friendly but saying to people
stay away from the border it's not going
to work
[Music]
probably not i mean as you say people
are coming
um for reasons which are beyond the
control of the us government i mean the
terrible situation in venezuela due to
this mismanagement of the socialist
government there the situation in in
central america
due to again lots of corrupt governments
there and
gangsterism the situation even in mexico
due to the drug cartels i mean they
killed like something like 10 000 people
only last year
these are all things that biden can't
can't control so so
i would would agree that that people are
going to come
whatever he says and that's when i think
and i say that they are not prepared
because when when you have a narrative
that is unifying and telling people that
you're going gonna
fix the immigration laws and you're not
being open borders because it has never
been the narrative but
you're gonna fix what was done in the
past you're essentially not considering
that when people in central america are
the ones waiting in mexico
are listening to it with hope so these
people is not like us
economical migrants saying like we
cannot just wait to go to the embassy
before we get the visa to come to
europe because of pandemic issues these
people are fleeing persecution they are
and they are not secure they are they
they're outside with nothing to eat
so you cannot tell these people stay
away and wait hold on until we fix
something or we create a plan for you so
then why the urgency
why not fixing the narrative at the
beginning and promising people with a
lot of hope
okay picking up on that point in recent
years tens of thousands of people from
central america and mexico
have tried to make their way into the
u.s many ending up stranded in refugee
camps along the border
the trump administration tried to close
the border altogether now under joe
biden's leadership that policy
is slowly beginning to change
they come from honduras venezuela
guatemala fleeing violence and poverty
in their homeland
for years many have lived in camps like
this in mexico on the border to their
dream destination
the us with biden hope and movement are
returning to a stall situation
volunteers like sister norma accompany
small groups across the border
now there is a possibility for a person
who is politically persecuted and who
fears for their life to have their case
reconsidered
and that also means crossing onto
american soil where they're assisted by
aid organizations
meanwhile more families are coming
attracted by the prospect of fair
treatment
but the application process is long
while the us needs migrants as labor
force whether these people will receive
asylum or residency
is far from certain will refugees soon
have a chance to stay in the u.s
under biden
good question anna your personal
response to seeing those pictures
well i mean i'm from central america
this is um
impotent feeling that creates um you
feel powerless
powerless totally and and and the thing
is yes it will exist and yes they will
reform
i i trust and i believe that this is
what is going to happen because again
i have so much faith and so much uh
respect towards the organization and
grassroots organization that has pushed
this further
in the united states so it will
eventually happen it just takes so much
time and in the meantime
for example the kids that are still
waiting in detention centers
uh they call it in spanish um yeletas
which is freezers
you know and so i just wanna
insist in this in the meantime all this
is fixed
is the lives of humans and kids still in
these detention centers
joseph as an activist i just wonder i
saw a sentence this week which i thought
was quite interesting because it seemed
to me to describe a balance in the
situation
that is a cruel balance but perhaps a
realistic one the sentence goes like
this to let some people in
you need to keep many others out
you see it as a there's only so much pie
and if i have less pie
then um i'm losing so what we need we
need to come
realize that we have the resources to
take care of
everyone um everyone in the whole world
everyone in the whole wide world
because we have nowhere else to go if we
don't take care of everyone in this
whole wide world what are we doing and
why are we doing it so we're trapped
in this mindset of you know these my
little nation state guarding my little
resources and i can't do it but we have
the technology we understand technology
now
technology flows across borders we have
the capacity to track people moving
across borders we don't need
we can have these open borders in europe
because we
have the ability to track people as
they're moving across if we can send
goods and services and capital across
borders
why can't we afford the same to people
it's an attractive vision
yeah and i don't think technology is a
problem right we
um we can of course we can track people
where they go um
but data protection laws in uh europe
say you can't we even that problem with
our covert vaccine tracking device on
our
mobile phones which which you know
people don't have to have
unlike in shall we say china where
they're forced to
and um and i for one am in favor
of as much individual freedom as
possible in europe is a
is not a fortress by the way it is an
island of freedom in a sea of unfreedom
and
i don't want to have to
restrict that for instance with the
technological devices you're talking
about
tracking everybody where they're going i
would
prefer to be able to go across to to to
france or to poland tomorrow
and nobody knows i'm there um and and
nobody cares
and and i can do you know unless i start
using my credit card or
going online then then facebook or
whatever no no
no you know knows who i am but you know
the government isn't following what i'm
doing
and it's this freedom that i want to
protect
and and i have to balance that
against letting in a whole you know i
mean how many people can you let in and
still keep this freedom
it sounds like i'm defending a privilege
and i am i'm defending the privilege of
freedom
um and i i'm very sorry but if if
the alternative is oh let everyone in
have them a marker
see where they're going then no thank
you i'd rather not have that george
orwellian state i'd rather have the
situation
we have now the thing is
this is happening unfortunately
unfortunately
what i like about what you said is that
why are we using this technology
in the wrong hands so let me rephrase it
migration is a business but not
for the right purposes it's a business
because technology technological
companies
with an industry even face recognition
it's been in the way of creation
for what we know about frontiers perhaps
we will talk about that later
so my point is there's billions border
control
exactly there's billions invested
there's
billions of money being invested which
basically essentially enables the right
wing
and a very conservative narrative to
continue and controlling us
so that will eventually happen and
technology is already being deployed
but for the wrong direction when
when we talk about migrants and i want
to pick up something that you said
the problem of facts not being
taken into account anymore which is a
big problem
is that we are not seeing that migrants
contribute way more
than what for example europe is spending
in controlling them
but since we don't care about data then
that's when
technology and these companies spend
much more money in making their business
themselves
no i'm so glad you pointed out the
facial recognition technology so the
world where you could travel to paris
or rome and no one knew where you were
that's gone um the moment you're
at a train station the moment you're at
uh an airport
these major hubs of transportation and
we need that in the fight against
terrorism so on the one hand we
understand
that we need this in the fight against
terrorism but we don't understand that
we could be using it
to have much more humane borders okay
can i just move away from
the the debate about technology
migration is also about it's about
politics it's about
economics and it's about culture tell me
a little bit about that
um so yeah so that's where i think you
know in the united states we really see
ourselves as a nation of
immigrants um it would be better if we
also saw ourselves as a nation of
colonial conquest but i think
we're kind of slowly getting there as
the generation shifts um
nation very troubled by racism as well
europeans can learn so much about
you know how constructive policy on
racism from america
but we're also we're also very they're
also extremely troubled by what we see
and hear
obviously right so i think yeah the
issue with europe is europe still
has this concept of itself you know
these
nation states these ethnicities i'm
french i'm german we're white french
we're white german without understanding
that the concept of europe uh
historically was more around the
mediterranean so you have people on the
mediterranean now
who are no longer considered european
but historically in hellenic culture
were so the issue is where do you start
looking right and i think
european culture right now has been
stuck since the age of conquest and
exploration
okay go on yeah yeah
i just don't want to add more because
i'm not european and
i don't know i would like to hear from
from from one from europe what what do
you think about this because i
from a migrant perspective point of view
when i came here in 2015 and then i see
all this welcoming narrative and all the
narrative that you know i see happening
now in the united states
being super diplomatic and super correct
when you
refer to migrants and yet you see
that not much has been advanced towards
real inclusion
so is that the europe that okay we're on
europe and most people in the eu seem to
have
tacitly at least uh to to have agreed to
look the other way
while official agencies do the dirty
work of keeping immigrants out of the
continent that has led to the cruel
practice known
as pushbacks please
please anyone help us please cries for
help
from refugees off the greek coast their
inflatable boats are constantly being
attacked by mass assailants
and rendered unseaworthy both european
border agency frontex
as well as the greek government deny
that such a legal action is taking place
but there is video footage to prove it
in the southern mediterranean meanwhile
eu-funded libyan militias are
threatening the work of sea rescuers
like ci
more and more refugees are now taking
the dangerous route toward the canary
islands
for most this is the end of the line
[Music]
the situation is even worse in the
balkans
in the bosnian libra camp 30 refugees
share one tent
most want to move on quickly to the eu
inshallah we try again and again because
crochet push back we are good
again we push back we are go again
is the eu keeping out refugees at all
costs
and are people like us eu citizens ellen
prepared to look the other way there's a
was that a caricature that i the that i
just said just now or are we
willing to look away while the dirty
work is done for us
well your your your film was very
uh biased
the fact is these things happen and they
shouldn't happen right let's put let's
and yes they're due to covet among other
things they don't get the
the attention they deserve right that
mustn't happen at the same time
what your film didn't say is that
hundreds of thousands make it to europe
every year they are processed in a no in
a in an
orderly fashion uh about 90 of them
apply for asylum and they don't get it
because
you know and then they go to a court and
30
of the decisions against them are then
reversed by the court which is means
that things are working in
in europe and also talking about frontex
basically
frontex has saved since its inception
around about 26.
hundreds of thousands of people right
fished them out of the water
saved them from from people smugglers
fought against
pirates and that kind of thing and
i think it's a mixed bag right but if
you
let's hear the other side of the
argument before we heard it in the film
didn't we i mean the fact is
we are and i just want to say one thing
if you had been as long and
i mean when i came to germany in in the
60s
right as an as an english-speaking
migrant
i was treated like you know you know
and and at that time no one could
imagine that would
that we today we'd have something like
the welcome culture
i mean we've we aren't we haven't
understood that we're a nation of
immigrants the way united states has
since at least john f kennedy so it's
been
you know and obviously it's going to
take some time
before that seeps down in in i mean you
have to
hand it to the germans with something
like 2015
it would have been unimaginable only 10
years before
point second that's true it's working to
a certain extent
and yes there is a much more welcoming
culture than before as i said
in 2015 when i arrived here that was
impressed and i've never seen anything
like that from a
human rights perspective such a
welcoming attitude two million
volunteers
mainly germans or europeans welcoming um
asylum seekers
yet the problem is that it got stuck
somewhere between 2016 2017 and we know
what happened politically speaking
in places like germany um but
this was the fear and panic that joe
talked about earlier this was
you said you understand the fear that
people feel i think that's you're
referring to the same thing there
yes exactly people saw too many people
flooding into this country and then got
afraid
and it created an entire opposition uh
which was there but not that active but
now it's very active and it's very out
there
so the problem with with what's
happening afterwards is like
in 2015 i saw this hope and i saw this
welcoming attitude
but somehow it's been changing a lot
over the last years
and there is desperation we still have
how many people more than 30 000 people
still stuck in greece
with no hopes of what's going to happen
with them
many of them actually four thousand of
them are young people in the age of
schools so
whether they continue or they just let's
send them home it's just that
we need to make a decision soon
and regarding frontiers i just cannot
say anything good about this
unfortunately i mean i work with
organizations that are
right now on the edge in the verge to be
criminalized for 20 years in
sentences for saving lives and only
it's just it's just very powerless how
it feels to
really express how people are feeling
out there so it's not about me or what
about you anymore i mean even the
organizations that i was running now i
hand it over to younger
generations because i have hope in the
same way that it's happening in the
united states
with young people changing and working
tireless to tireless to change the
system that it will happen here as well
wouldn't be in the hands of many of us i
would let it to the younger generations
that they decide what
what's the future that they want to have
you run forward as though you're about
to say something but i mean
look look one of the big differences
between united states and europe is the
neighborhood
you do not have among the
hundreds of thousands going north to the
united states
um a percentage of terrorists uh
we do our neighborhood is syria uh
uh people come the the guy in the in the
film coming from
pakistan state sponsor of terrorism
right i'm not saying he's a terrorist
you know but amongst those coming from
pakistan from iraq from syria
uh even from morocco across from libya
there is a percentage of terrorists and
they have to be
screened out right and um and frontex is
doing a very good job with that and the
reason why
there is a problem with some of these
activities seawatch and for instance
is that they don't do it um in
a good way and that's one of the
problems why there is this uh
these illegal boats coming from from
from turkey and landing in greece is
when they get on board we don't know
where they're going so
it's i'm sorry but we have to deal
with realities we're not living in an
island
we're living in a very dangerous
neighborhood we used to think it's only
israel right when they said our
neighborhood is dangerous
now we we realized that in fact
europe is not the old europe of the
greeks around the mediterranean
because half of that is occupied by well
right joseph and yet um to conflate
terrorism with immigration um makes
sense
i mean you know the the issue that we
have is
homegrown terrorism so to speak right so
keeping people out is not going to keep
us
safe and that's what we have to
understand so i definitely agree we need
to be screening people but we need to be
screening people by either
letting them reach our shores or going
to where they are
we've run out of time i'm afraid it's
been a great debate great guests
yeah we've been looking at immigration
policy on either side of the atlantic
joe
biden's new administration their policy
if we've given you plenty of food for
thought and i trust we have
come back next time around until then
bye bye and cheers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you